hey guys i'm abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen so today we're going to
be chatting about female fitness
competitors this is something that I've
gotten a lot of questions about
specifically whether or not it is safe
there are a ton of popular female
bodybuilders and fitness competitors on
YouTube that have really made this idea
of female bodybuilding and fitness
competitions a lot more popular and
well-known now before we get into
anything I watch of course flag that the
information in this video is for
education and entertainment purposes
only and is not intended to prescribe or
make any recommendations so all we speak
to your doctor and a dietician about
your unique health case also I want to
of course remind you that I am wearing
my snack shirt today and it's it's
getting a little tight with me and baby
in here but definitely check out the
link below to see my entire merch line
so you definitely want to help support
that because a portion of proceeds are
going towards Sick Kids Foundation ok
now let's get into the video I first
want to talk a little bit about a
typical Fitness competitors diet now
every competitors diet and plan is going
to totally depend on their coach their
category and the state of their body
when they begin but generally speaking
there is a bulking phase which is where
you're maybe trying to build muscle
often with a caloric increase and later
there's a cutting phase and that's where
you're trying to lose body fat while
still maintaining as much of that muscle
mass that you can note that putting your
body into a catabolic and anabolic state
at the same time is really really hard
to do but more on that later now I'm
going to be it totally transparent I'm
not super jazzed about what is going on
to prepare young women to have to step
on the stage and have their bodies
critiqued but I also acknowledge that
you have every right to want to change
your body to look a certain way and I
have zero right or desire to judge that
that is not what this video is about
what I want to talk about is some of the
risks and concerns that have been
uncovered in the literature that are
specific and unique to this population
so you can embark on your health and
fitness journey in the healthiest way
possible first of all let's talk
about the physical dangers and risks
starting with potential nutrition
deficiencies one of the major concerns
with bodybuilding and fitness
competition prep is the risk for
micronutrient deficiencies and this is
because of the tendencies for some
bodybuilders to have to severely
restrict certain foods in their diet and
only include a small range of repeated
safe foods on their plan some studies on
dieting competitors observe deficiencies
in micronutrients like vitamin D calcium
zinc magnesium and iron having said that
a lot of this evidence is from the early
days of bodybuilding so it's very
possible that these micronutrient
deficiencies were maybe more common in
those days due to very premature
understanding of bodybuilding nutrition
and drastic elimination diets we've
definitely come a long way having said
that in a lot of cases especially for
women it may be useful to take a
multivitamin if you are severely
restricting calories or certain types of
food in preparation for competition
there is also the common risk of fluid
imbalances now in the final days and
hours before a fitness competition also
known as peak week many bodybuilders
will attempt to manipulate their fluid
and electrolyte levels to improve their
muscularity and to get them that kind of
ripped appearance now in order to define
their muscularity during that final week
bodybuilders will kind of dramatically
increase their water intake sometimes to
as much as 10 liters per day while also
taking diuretics then the day before the
competition bodybuilders may be
instructed to dramatically cut their
water intake in order to dehydrate their
body sometimes getting no water for 24
hours before showtime
while continuing on their diuretic
supplements now I know we being
conditioned to believe that more water
is better but drinking 10 liters of
water a day and then flushing that out
with diuretics can easily cause water
intoxication hyponatremia and
hypokalemia which taken together may be
fatal
other side effects can include irregular
heartbeat fatigue seizures GI distress
muscle cramping and weakness headaches
and
more playing with water might even make
you look too flat depending on how and
when it's done so you could actually put
yourself at risk and not even get the
desired look for competition now let's
talk about some supplement concerns
while the supplement industry's market
is worth as much as 37 billion dollars a
year most researchers and health care
professionals caution their use because
there really isn't clear evidence that
they work and are beneficial to our
health on top of that because
supplements are not necessarily so well
regulated there are a ton of illegal
substances that make their way onto
store shelves and honestly they have
killed people according to a 2016 study
it's estimated that around 23,000
emergency room visits a year are linked
to supplements because of the lack of
regulation consumers don't really know
all of the ingredients in supplements
and dosages could even vary from pill to
pill that is really scary stuff and we
need greater regulation if it's causing
people to die there's also potential
side effects of some common supplements
used for fitness competition from
anxiety insomnia kidney and liver damage
infertility and even death you really
have to trust your coach to prescribe
these cocktails of supplements and drugs
in appropriate doses for you I don't
know about you but that feels like it
takes a lot of trust now let's talk
about some of the psychological risks
including body dissatisfaction and
disordered eating
in one study one-third of a group of
bodybuilders reported anxiety short
tempers or anger during competition prep
furthermore 81.5% of them in the group
reported a preoccupation with food which
is a precursor of course to disordered
eating this is especially a concern
among female fitness competitors as one
study found that among female
competitive bodybuilders about 42% used
to be anorexic 67% were terrified of
becoming fat and 50% experienced
uncontrollable urges to eat furthermore
research together from the National
Eating Disorders website found that
among female high school athletes for
1.5% reporter disordered eating and a
sort of eating affected 62% of female
athletes in aesthetic weight class
sports I'll also just never forget a
story that my personal trainer told me
about the competition floor
he said that young female competitors
all bring these suitcases filled with
cookies candies cupcakes doughnuts you
know all the things that they haven't
allowed themselves to eat while doing
their prep diet then the moment that
they get off stage they tend to go crazy
and literally eat until they make
themselves sick so while you may look at
a fitness competitor and assume that
they are the picture of perfect health
it's very possible that some of these
behaviors may tell a very different
story this is just another perfect
example of how one's physical body is
not necessarily a great depiction of
their actual health you really cannot
judge a book by its cover
now let's talk about my bread and butter
fertility anytime that you're severely
restricting calories or increasing
activities you put a woman at risk for
hormonal imbalance which may in turn
impact fertility and overall health
in one study 25% of female bodybuilding
competitors reported abnormal menstrual
cycles while another study reported that
women complained of menstrual
irregularity within the first month of
competition prep the researchers found
that caloric restriction led to a
decline in fat and body mass which
resulted in the absent menstrual cycle
restrictive diets excessive exercise low
body weight and nutritional deficiencies
from bodybuilding can lead to what we
call the female athlete triad which is a
condition defined by a low energy
available with or without disordered
eating be menstrual dysfunction and see
low bone density research has also found
that both resistance training and energy
restriction are associated with
alterations in KIBRA productive hormones
ultimately resulting in estrogen
deficiency now only does this have an
impact on fertility but a lack of
estrogen can also cause a disruption in
bone remodeling which can increase the
risk of fractures and ultimately
osteoporosis
let's chat about the big elephant in the
room weight and metabolic declines one
of the main criticisms of rapid weight
loss or low calorie diets is that it may
slow down a person's metabolic rate this
in turn makes it very difficult and
potentially even virtually impossible to
keep the weight off once a person stops
dieting and resumes to normal eating
even if their normal eating is still
very balanced and healthy this combined
with the psychological drive to binge
eat all of the forbidden foods after a
show makes it very easy to see how a lot
of female Fitness competitors kind of
bounce up to an even higher weight post
show than they were before they began
not surprisingly there are a lot of
hormonal adaptations to blame for these
shifts one studies have found that a
low-calorie diet may decrease thyroid
hormone levels which can decrease a
person's overall metabolic rate to
leptin which is our fullness hormone
lives in body fats so when we lower our
body fat levels leptin levels also
decline studies have shown that a low
calorie diet with an effort to promote
fat loss may decrease leptin levels
resulting in competitors feeling
basically constantly hungry and
prompting them to overeat three ghrelin
which is our hunger hormone increases in
the body will be fast so researchers
have found that a low calorie diet can
increase ghrelin stimulating
participants to eat more for researchers
also found that a low calorie diet
decreases our natural testosterone
levels and since testosterone plays an
important role in increasing muscle
protein synthesis and muscle mass it
could negatively impact metabolically
active muscle mass n5 research has found
that a low calorie diet may increase
korzel which has been shown to increase
protein breakdown and healthy subjects
again impacting metabolically active
tissue bottom line before I leave you
let's get one thing straight I am by no
means trying to say that you shouldn't
become a female fitness competitor or
bodybuilder if that is what brings you
joy my job as a dietitian is to try to
understand this athlet
trend to dive into the culture and
explore the possible concerns with
following this type of lifestyle and of
course to give you the tools that you
need to do it in the safest way possible
my recommendation seek out an
experienced sports dietitian who can
really help guide you through this
process in the safest way possible and
do a real deep dive to ensure that
you're psychologically ready for what it
entails personally I know that this
would take me to some dangerously dark
places so it would never be a healthy
sport for me
I am simply presenting the literature
and what it has uncovered in terms of
concerns and risks and that way you can
hopefully make the most informed choices
for yourself on that note please keep
the comments kind and respectful if you
yourself have found something that has
helped you along on your fitness journey
I would love to hear about it in the
comments below if you like this video be
sure to give it the thumbs up like I
said leave us lots of great comments I'd
love to hear your experiences don't
forget to subscribe and I will see you
next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]